[MUSIC PLAYING]
AVI MUCHNIK: I'm Avi Muchnik.
I'm one of the
co-founders of Aviary.
There are thousands of photo
editing apps out there.
What we've always looked to
do is simplify the experience
for the end user.
We want something
that, no matter
what your background in tech is,
you could just literally pick
it up and in less
than six seconds
understand how to use it and
make your photos look great.
One of the most amazing things
about the Android platform
is our communication
with our users.
It's not really us responding
to bug reports that we see.
It's really this
ongoing two-way dialogue
we have with people,
both through beta tests
and also through
ratings and reviews.
We can see things as they're
happening in real time.
We can talk with our
community to find out
what features they like
and what they don't like,
and what things they would
love to see in the app
that we haven't even
thought of and implement
that in real time.
OLIVIA SCHAFER: Working
with the Android Dev Console
has been amazing compared
to other platforms.
In particular,
with Android we are
able to see metrics about them.
We're able to
search through them.
We're able to actually
respond to users.
With the new tools, I
would say that we're
able to identify
issues twice as fast.
It makes it easy
for us to search
through the reviews,
contact users when
we need to get more information
from them, and just in general,
it has saved me a
tremendous amount of time,
anywhere between 5
to 10 hours a week.
BLAKE DARLING:
Android in general
is usually impactful
to the Aviary team.
It's over 2/3 of our user base.
We use Search Within
Reviews every day.
We use it to validate
new features.
For example, we recently
released a new Discover
feature.
We'll search Discover to
see what users are saying
about that and let us
know if they like it
or if there are
problems with it,
and that helps us make
product decisions.
The Ratings and Reviews feature
has been immensely impactful,
having the ability to quickly
drill into issues by device,
by app version, by Android
version, and then also
anecdotally, sift through
what users are saying
and the actual
words they're using
is pretty unique
to the platform.
And it helps us develop
much more quickly.
OLIVIA SCHAFER: Responding
to users in the Dev Console
has been immensely
impactful for us.
For instance, recently
we released a version
that resolved a pretty
major bug that was
affecting many of our users.
I went into the Dev
Console, responded
to all of the people who
were experiencing the bug,
and about 50% of them actually
went back in and ended up
updating the interview.
AVI MUCHNIK: One
of things I love
about building for the Android
platform is how quickly we
can test and deploy on it.
We have this fantastic
beta community on Android
that can test out new features.
BLAKE DARLING: And
that helps us identify
bugs or what features they
like or don't like much more
quickly.
Being able to do that allows us
to iterate two to three times
faster on Android compared
to other platforms, which is
usually impactful for our app.
Photo Editor by
Aviary is meant to be
a dead simple but powerful
photo editing tool.
Having that dialogue
with our users
through the tools the Developer
Console and the Play Store
gives us, we're able
to iterate much faster
and deliver on an easy,
simple interface, which
is really powerful for us.